look the Chargers Chris they were they
were almost the 1 seed in 2018 we talked
earlier about that
Ravens Chargers playoff game if the
Chargers had beaten the Ravens on that
Saturday night at home they very well
may have been the top seed what a
difference you know we saw how close it
was this year for the 49ers and the
Seahawks in the NFC it was pretty close
last year for the Chiefs and the
Chargers in the AFC and how different
that season might have been how
different our perception of the charges
would be right now but you know even
though they don't have Philip Rivers
even though they don't have a big-time
franchise quarterback right out of the
gates you know and you can hear the
whole podcast at youtube.com slash NBC
Sports wherever you can find your
podcast the full conversation available
you know Tyrod Taylor's a lot of belief
in Tyrod Taylor all right this is one of
those teams that I think he's in a great
spot nobody's gonna be saying oh the
Chargers gonna be pretty good this year
and that's one of those ways that teams
like the Chargers sneak up on people
yeah well the AFC West I think has a
couple of those teams really all three
teams other than the Kansas City Chiefs
you know I think the Chargers and the
Denver Broncos are two teams
specifically to mean that I have my eyes
on but the Chargers yeah I mean again we
know how close they were in so many
games last year that could have turned
out different ways to where you know
they could have been in the playoff
conversation certainly Phillip Rivers
didn't have his best year and we know
that but I think they're trying to tell
you they're trying to play a different
style of football a different brand this
year they're gonna play through their
defense and their run game bore anthony
lens a run game expert so I think with
him and having a quarterback like Tyrod
Taylor who does take care of the
football but does have physical ability
to make plays you know that are off
schedule I think they're gonna try to
play that and then like Chris Harris jr.
said there's just so much to excite you
about this defense and I think you know
they're gonna take the approach a little
bit maybe like we saw you know the New
England Patriots or the Broncos team of
20 2015 I was in saying the Patriots of
last year where they played through the
defense and try to win games 23 to 17 or
20 to 14 and I think their team is built
to do that and they have a very good
chance of doing it
yeah and I I agree and Chris Harris jr.
look this guy is a great great story
undrafted and part of the conversation
included his experience in 2011 a lot
like what guys are going through this
year he comes in as an undrafted free
agent in an off season with no offseason
program because of the lockout and he
still makes the roster and he ends up
becoming one of the best nickel corners
in all of football he's not a big guy he
is incredibly skilled and and this is
one of the and that's why I'm surprised
the Broncos let him get away Chris
because this is one of the great success
stories for John Elway finding Chris
Harris jr. and having that organization
develop him into what he is and now they
see him leave for a team in the division
and they're gonna have to worry about
him twice per year
he knows the personnel he knows drew
Locke he knows a lot about that team and
I'm a little extra nervous about playing
the charges if I'm a Broncos fan this
year yeah well I get that they're
certainly mean the Broncos were excited
about what they have on the offensive
side of the ball some of the young
talent I think that's one of those
offenses that you and I both look at to
go watch out everybody it's going to
explode on the NFL this year between the
system and the players but but yeah
you're right I mean listen Chris Harris
jr. experienced winning pedigree and
then still an incredible amount of
talent and high level play there to be
had with Chris Harris jr. Denver just
felt like they probably couldn't pay
them and do it deal with it but that's
that's a huge game for the Chargers but
you break down the Chargers you sit here
to go like wow they got Lynn Bell Joe
Joseph on the defensive line they needed
some help on the interior d tackle we
know they didn't need pass rushers they
got kenneth murray in the first round
and linebacker holy cow
Derwin james one of the the second-best
safety in football to me only behind
jamal adams you know two good corners
and casey hayward and Chris Harris jr. I
mean that's unbelievable they improved
their offensive line getting Bryan
Bulaga they traded for Trey Turner with
the Carolina Panthers that was really
their big concern on the offensive side
of the ball in my opinion is just yeah
offensive line play is
below-average the last few years with
the Chargers so I think they did a
really good job of addressing some of
the needs they needed to you know
address and and to take their team you
know to I don't want to say the next
level but certainly to improve them to
get them back in the playoff combo and I
would be shocked Mike if they're not in
the playoff combo late December sitting
there blast you three games fighting for
a spot especially with seven teams now
per conference and one last thing to
keep in mind Tyrod Taylor 26 and 23 as a
starter think about the teams that he
has played for think about the teams he
has started for specifically those
Buffalo teams think about the weapons he
had at his disposal in Buffalo think
about the weapons he'll have at his
disposal with the Chargers right maybe
now we know why they they didn't pursue
Cam Newton maybe we know now why they're
willing to let Justin Herbert sit for a
year or so maybe it's not going to be
Tyrod Taylor just holding the spot until
they think Herbert's ready to enter the
fray
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports